[Music]
hey what's going on guys the cat is out
the bag the god logic shirts are out
click the link in the description and
head on over to God logic.com to
purchase our first release we just read
let's go I'll see you guys with a shirt
peace all right what's going on
everybody I'm here with Imam heed again
uh if you guys watched our previous
video it was on the authority of the
previous scriptures from the quran's
lens what is the Quran talk about it and
today um in this video we're going to be
talking on the person of Jesus Christ so
uh Imam wed bahed I'm sorry if you would
like to go ahead and uh just give us a
summary or generality of what your
thoughts are on this and uh basically
I'm I'm following your lead on here okay
okay well let me Begin by saying in the
name of God the most compassion most
merciful
um so so I'm going to talk a little bit
about Jesus uh peace be upon him and I
have a few notes here that I wanted to
to uh to share and um the first one
which I I know is something that is
often discussed is you hear these ideas
you hear this rhetoric or or or language
that asserts that Jesus was a Muslim and
so people were asked how can that be the
case Now understand this is that in
Arabic the word the Muslim is really the
one who does the action okay so if I use
the example of the driver his name is
John Smith it doesn't tell us when you
say the word driver it doesn't tell us
his name it doesn't tell us his birth
date or his death date it is simply he's
doing the action of driving okay so so
Jesus is a Muslim in the sense that he
is someone who submitted himself to
God's will okay so this is this this is
the uh this is the first thing that
doesn't mean that he prayed the way that
that we pray today it doesn't mean that
he had the laws the way that we have the
laws today but in terms of submitting to
God and and really he's he is a preacher
of Islam of submission to God in the
Bible the Bible has Jesus say um love
the Lord with all your heart mind and
soul love your neighbor as yourself all
the law and the prophets hang on these
two points so this really is a beautiful
description of submission to God's will
which in Arabic is called Islam so this
is the uh this is the one thing I I
wanted to Sure mention oh yeah go ahead
go ahead go ahead okay yeah let's go
point point point this a good for sure
so um that's actually one of my favorite
topics on is whether or not Jesus is a
Muslim right and and I I understand
everything you said by breaking down the
word itself linguistically Al one who
does the action of submitting to God's
will now so I like to throw this in here
because as a to be a Muslim and to
submit to God's will that presumes that
you have a particular concept of God
right you can't say that you know you
believe in a statute that's God that's
the one God and so you submit to that
and be and call yourself a muslim okay
right and so it depends on what your
concept of the one God is um that that
you're submitting to that would qualify
you to be a mus or that you're truly
submitting to God what do you think so
the the Shema which which is a statement
in the Bible which which Jesus recites
yeah hear this oh Israel the Lord your
God is one God and the Old Testament
particularly describes God you're not
you're not supposed to make Raven images
of God you know that that and when we
were having this discussion in in the
previous discussion that God is not a
confined or in a in a physical being so
the point I'm making here if we're
talking about God concept if what you
just mentioned is that the concept of
God that Jesus has is the same concept
that Moses has and S similarly the same
concept that Muhammad had the same
concept the concept of The One and Only
God the Creator suer Universe the one
who is not given birth to any he's not
you know in other words he's not he
doesn't have a father and a mother you
know he is the uncaused cause he's the
first cause as as it said in certain in
philosophy so it's the same concept it's
it's not worshiping a statue or
worshiping a tree and asserting that
that's God it's not it's not that kind
of thing at all right so so then with
what you because you just gave very
clear and specific descriptions and
qualities of the god or the concept of
God that um we're saying Moses Jesus and
Muhammad believed in okay right and so
here's something that's that's important
because we were talking about language
or descriptions that would kind of Le
Mis lead people to apply weaknesses or
mischaracterizations of God right um in
in the scriptures like for example in
the Quran very clear that Allah he's not
begotten nor does he beget right there's
nothing like him in creation um he you
know we're his slaves he's and he's our
Master he's our Lord stuff like that
he's not a father right um Jesus
obviously and so did Moses they had this
concept of God that God was our heavenly
father specifically Jesus says that he's
God's one and only son is that can can
someone be claiming that and still be a
Muslim or in line with Muhammad's
concept of God this is a good question
and um I I I almost alluded to this in
our our previous conversation
now Jesus and Moses and I think this is
I think I don't think you'll disagree
with me about this is that they they
didn't understand this term father in in
a literal sense this is a this is a
metaphorical sense or something they
call in Arabic that this this is this is
a a an expression that is meant to
denote the respect and appreciation and
things like that not in a not in a not
in a literal sense so if so and actually
this even goes back to our previous
discussion on on language on on on how
the the respective uh faiths use
language now this term father um if I
understood your let me go back to your
question your question is can can
Muslims use this term is that your term
or can Muslims go so Muslims can go
along with this term in the sense and
understand saying I want to make this
very clear in the sense that in their in
the cultural uh environment of Jesus and
and and the uh biblical figures in their
cultural sense they can use this term
they use they use this term but this not
understood in a literal sense now let me
finish you know I'm I'm old so I forget
okay so you take it now you take now
let's take this let's take this
a let's take let's take this let's take
this a step further mhm okay taking this
taking this a step further now the Quran
as I mentioned previously that the Quran
comes along and it tells us not to use
certain language because of the wrong
pictures that it creates okay so this is
also the issue of Son of God this is
also the issue of Son of God now the
Bible clearly clearly I want to say that
again
clearly uses the expression Son of God
in a metaphorical sense in the New
Testament and I think it's in the
beginning of Matthew or towards um I
think beginning Matthew in the in The
Sermon on the Mount it says blessed are
the peacemakers for they shall be called
the children of God okay so and in in
addition to the many Expressions inside
of the Old Testament where the term Son
of God is is used so it's used in a
metaphorical sense and in eastern
cultures the to to call somebody uh for
examp example Uncle
Auntie son or daughter I mean these
these are very common but Islam comes
the Quran comes along and it says don't
use this language because of the these
reasons and in an American context in an
American context we understand this very
well America United States of America
has had a long standing
racial racial not one problem racial
problems and much much as this has been
expressed in God concept and when I mean
or in imagery of God I should put it
like that in the imagery of God you you
could go to some Churches where Jesus is
a a white man and then you have some
Churches where Jesus is as if he's from
the Democratic Republic of
Congo okay with the afro sometimes
sometimes there's an afro now why is
this even why is this an issue why is
this an issue because the language now
from Muslim perspective it doesn't
matter what color Jesus was but the
point I'm saying is because Jesus is
presented as Son of God yeah is
understood as Son of God or got himself
depending on which way you want to look
at
it this why these issues become
important so to remove those issues
those those type of problems the Quran
tells us not to use this language okay
does it make sense what I'm telling you
of course I understand everything you're
saying so yeah so basically there is a
correct sense in which you can
understand Allah to be the father so can
I yeah okay okay in the cultural
environment in the cultural environment
of Jesus or in the cultural environment
of the figures of the judeo-christian
tradition the in that cultural
environment and they're talking about in
what we could call the Jewish uh realm
yeah okay but they did not understand
this in a literal physical way they
didn't have they they were against they
were against images they didn't have in
the synagogue they didn't have images of
a man and say this is God they didn't
they didn't do that they weren't allowed
they weren't even allowed to to do that
according to the Bible right
so again this is one of the functions of
the Quran one of the functions of the
Quran is to tell us don't use this
language use Clear language so we refer
to God not by the word father Muslims
I'm saying Muslims follows the Quran and
Muhammad peace be upon them don't use
the word father Muslims use the word for
example
which means the nourisher and caretaker
sustainer caretaker that God is the one
who he's your caretaker that God is your
master god is your
provider so this language cannot be
understood misunderstood but the
language of God is be of of God is
father or then the the the consequence
of that God is son or using God Son the
Son of God these things C can create the
misunderstandings which is certainly
have happened in human history I think I
think any again anything can but like
when you say but it has it's not just a
theory it has that's true so thank you
for acknowledging that no yeah you're
absolutely right so I would I would also
go along with that um you know because
we're talking about you know Islamic
theology right okay um
so I'm not going to let me ask you this
before I even make my comment um so are
you saying that like islamically that
once CE upon a time it was theologically
okay to refer to and think of Allah as
the father um but now since that since
Islam came and after those
misunderstandings he then in a in a
lesser term abrogates it yeah this is
this is a good question and essentially
my answer is exactly that in essence so
let me repeat the answer so make sure
that it's clear for yourself and for
anyone who happens to view this
discussion in the environment of
Jesus Jesus was not from Las Vegas
Nevada right Jesus was from the area
that we call Palestine M okay in that
environment you have this language of
for example father or the en or the
language of son okay you you this is the
way people talk and I I gave the example
off camera we're talking about you know
the word dog and things like that so
this was the this was the this was the
environment in which they spoke now from
from a concept of God because see father
is the provider the the the uh the
loving one and things of this nature so
what was stop us let me stay this Focus
before I go to the next thing so in that
environment if was if if they used it
then it's still not a problem because
they have a certain understanding of it
they're not misunderstanding it but when
that language escapes that cultural
environment and goes to a Roman or Greek
environment you know these are people
who believed in many gods and these are
people who whose mythology gods begets
gods and things like that then the
language
becomes understood in a literal sense
okay I can work with this so as long as
it's under the correct framework that
the prophets understood it and not going
outside of that to like the the Greek
mythology and all that kind of stuff
then uh essentially the essence of the
meaning of the word or term father and
how they meant it it's theologically
consistent loic consistent now what
happens is again the the Quran this book
the Quran it comes along to correct
these
misunderstandings and now the Quran is
also and Karen Armstrong I'm sure you
heard of her uh Karen Armstrong in in
her book u in one of her in one of her
books actually many of her books now I
think about it she has made the argument
that that kind of paraphrasing the
argument that Jesus and Muhammad you
know why is the why is the issue of
monotheism so important and so her
argument is again she's not a Muslim and
I don't think she's a Christian either
her argument is that because this stems
from citic culture that's her argument
and then her argument is
further is that the is that the Trinity
or you know the way of looking at God in
a physical sense in the sense that you
have this human being as as God not just
God's son but God himself that this is
you know more or less of a of a a
European way of looking at things
because these are people who were who
had these kinds of of of um of of ways
of of understanding in their mythology
okay okay so in line of thinking of the
way that uh you know Jesus taught about
the sunship or fatherhood of God and his
sunship or other people's sunship he he
would make a a distinction between
himself and then um others like you
mentioned like you know the peacemakers
they'll be children of God or prophets
or you know children of Israel as a
whole He points to himself as the um the
manages the begotten son or the the one
and only unique son of of the father who
he sent into the world and then he says
that as the as this son he has the
authority to um be honored the same way
the father is honored to judge on
Judgment day and stuff like that so um
there there certain there are many ways
to really address this part but from
from the quranic the quranic text it
says uh whosoever obeys the messenger
obeys God okay uh it says obey God and
obey the messenger right he again he who
obeys the messenger in fact obeys God
now this doesn't mean that the messenger
himself is God in this in this vers is
and obviously it's talking about Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him that's the
immediate reference but the point I'm
making is that even if even if for the
sake of argument to concede the point
even just even if even if we do that
that still doesn't mean because I think
what you're getting into I think you're
getting into the identity of Jesus as
being from your perspective God's uh God
right that's where is that where you're
going it's uh not necessarily so much
yet just on his theology like cuz if
you're cuz we're talking about him being
a Muslim man right a musl
but again you understand what Muslim
means Muslim is is not just someone who
wearing a cap right okay Muslim I mean
we in today's world we understand Muslim
as somebody who's wearing a cap yeah
yeah I understand what you're saying the
one who's doing the action of submission
all yes yeah and so I'm I'm saying
remember like we we broke down that when
we say submit to God the God we're
talking that's this particular God
that's a particular concept of God so
there is only one God right now that's
something that Muslims and Jews and
Christians agree upon there's only one
God now Muslims and Jews are pretty much
on the same page as to God but Muslims
and Christians are not always on the
same page because the majority of
Christians believe in Trinity the
majority of Christians believe then some
some Christians believe that Jesus
himself there's no Trinity at all but
rather Jesus is just everything is in
Jesus I forgot what the term modalism
mod yeah so there so um we we wouldn't
say that they're Christians well well
well nonetheless the the the the uh the
point I'm the overarching point I'm
making here is that is that um they are
that Jesus and Mos Muhammad they are
they are teaching the same thing in
terms of of God concept and that's
that's what I'm that's what I'm leaning
to that if if Jesus is teaching that
he's the son of God right um and
especially the unique Son of God oh let
me address that oh go ahead go I'm I'm
just making sure I keep go ahead go
ahead so if yeah if he's saying that
about himself obviously the Quran is
like referring to Jesus absolutely not
you know Allah does beget um he has no
children you know none can come to him
except as a servant right so if if Jesus
is teaching that he's the son of God who
is unique and different from everyone
else who has the authority to inherit
and be the heir of God and sit at his
right at his right side and rule that I
think goes directly against Islamic
theology about what Muhammad taught okay
so there I try to keep track of
everything that you were saying now let
me do the last part first you know about
Jesus being at the right hand of God now
the Quran talks about Jesus he says as
he is M that he is among those who are
close to God that's how the Quran talks
now are you understanding let me ask you
a question before I even move on are you
understanding this in a literal sense or
in a metaphorical sense literal in so
you're understanding this in a in in a
literal in a literal sense that that
there is a is a chair somewhere as a
throne somewhere that God is sitting on
it and that Jesus is is right there with
him is that you understand it in a
literal sense okay well I mean you're
welcome to to see it that way but
obviously we are not seeing we had this
whole discussion about the physicality
of God you know that the scripture in
this case the Quran that it doesn't it
it says that nothing is comparable to
God and we don't we we're not to see God
or under or conceptualize God in for
lack of a better word humanistic terms
so that's that's uh one part so anyway
in terms of being even if I conceded and
I'm not really I'm not doing that but
even for the sake of conversation I
conceded that Jesus was at the right
hand of God he's still in a
subservient uh situation because
according even according to the Bible
Accord to the Bible he says I can of
myself I can of my own self do nothing
and he says I do not do my own will or
follow my own will rather I follow the
will of the one who sent me so he's
always he's all even even from the
perspective of the New Testament he's
always presenting himself as as as a
servant not as not as the equal of not
as the the the equal of God now as a me
as someone whom God sent he certainly
has a a kind of uh authority of course
he's he's not he's not the janitor yeah
okay but but if if we Elevate his role
when we Elevate his role we
create big mistakes okay and we and and
and this is why and because of the
creation of the big mistakes the great
big mistakes is frankly is the notion
that this human being who according to
most most Christian uh historians only
preached for 3 years some of them say
six years but that this human being was
God himself not just a Son of God but
God
himself th this is a big uh this is a
big huge mistake a big huge mistake
which which which has been again I have
a feeling that you have come across this
type of information this issue of Jesus
being God I'm not I'm not going to
ignore Son of God for a moment but Jesus
being God this issue has been an issue
that has been disputed almost since the
very beginning okay so just to start a
little bit backwards right about the the
will um him saying that he submits to
the the the will of the one who sent him
right that's John 6:38 and so and
continuing that because remember I'm
thinking of this line of Jesus matching
Muslim theology right and if we continue
what he says there he says um and this
is the will of him who sent me
that all that he has given me I shall
lose none that all he has given me right
and then he continues and he says that
um that all to are to look to the son
and believe in him and I will raise him
up on the last day and he will have
eternal life right it it does does that
match Muslim theology if for Jesus to
say I'm the son who God has sent I'm
God's son who he sent that everyone is
to look to me for salvation and I'm
going to raise them up on Judgment Day
okay so if I I me again I'm trying to
keep track of everything that you you
you youve shared so I'll address it as I
understood what you what you said yes
sir okay so in in now first of all the
teachings are not just of Jesus but of
any of the messengers and prophets of
Allah of God that these teachings of
course they they they give a
transformation and this transformation
is referred to in religious language as
eternal life okay so this happens in a
worldly sense as well as a in in the
other world in the
afterlife okay this this type of this
the type of transformation and from a
Muslim side I mean I can give many
examples of individuals that we have
encountered over the years whose lives
have become completely changed a for the
better as a result of accepting the
message of the Prophet Muhammad so
similarly accepting the message of Jesus
okay and and so this gives a you know in
a sense an eternal life you you
understand what I'm saying what I'm
trying to say here what I'm trying to
say here this a couple of things if I'm
I'm trying I'm trying to keep track of
everything that's you're saying what I'm
trying to say here is number one it's
what's is being discussed is really the
the impact of the teachings of of a of
of one a teacher or teachers to whom God
I get what you're saying trust me so
you're saying the teachings can bring
them eternal life like if they're
adhering to that I get that yeah um so
but Jesus is specifically saying that he
he is going to be the one that gives
them eternal life not in the sense just
of his teachings but he says on the last
day I'm going to raise you up that's
what he says so we see that so when when
you say raise up I mean do you mean by
that that Jesus himself is going to be
the commander and chief that's going to
raise people from the grave is that is
that is that what you're saying yes sir
yes sir okay well I mean you know you're
welcome to say that that's what he said
mean no that's what you're that's what I
mean what I'm what I'm saying here okay
let's let's back up for a little bit let
me let me let me let me frame this in a
let me try to explain this in in a more
clear way now according to the New
Testament Jesus for example says I don't
even have a rock to sleep on you
remember that yeah okay Jesus and if I
go and find it Jesus says according to
according to the Bible he he there's an
incident where he goes into a town a
village and he wants to be in Disguise
you know he doesn't want people to know
who he is he doesn't people recognize
him but people recognize him anyway so
he is presented in these two
examples as someone who doesn't even
have the power to put on a good disguise
so if he doesn't have the power to go
put on the good disguise how can we
interpret this in the literal sense that
he's literally you know being the one
who is you know uh resurrecting people
from the from the from the graves so so
if you want so this so you have two
possibilities from the Islamic
perspective now a it could be
metaphorical language and B it could be
some issues of of of of of of uh of
Corruption of the teachings now there is
another there is there what that
is yeah so there's there's another um
there's another book I wish I had
brought it with me today let me get the
the reference here but there's there's
another
book that uh that that uh you might want
to read let me get the reference here so
uh This Book Is by John Shelby Spong and
it's called biblical literalism A GLE a
gentile
heresy and this book has has pretty much
and again the guy was not a joke the the
author of it was the Episcopal Bishop of
Newark you know he was a scholar he's
he's been a writer on I don't know if
you have heard this name but uh he's
someone who's been writing books on
Bible commentary uh he's I think he's
passed away now but he's someone who's
been writing books on the on religion
for 25 30 years yeah and and he's made
the argument that you know that these
types of references that you're talking
about and I'm going to give you the when
we finish I'm going to give you this
paper with this reference here okay that
all of these things he argues that these
are just literary devices that were
created for certain certain reasons so
anyway from Islamic perspective you have
those two possibilities okay and so what
what the Quran comes along and it says
it says look first of all no human being
can be God second of all that no that
you can't that no human being can be the
literal Son of God now as a metaphor as
a metaphor in that environment that's
one thing yeah but the Quran comes for
the entire world okay and it it it one
of his jobs is to make sure that God
concept is not misunderstood the idea of
of or monotheism that God is is very
strong with within Islam so that's part
so you had those two possibilities in
terms of interpreting the Bible verse
that you the Bible text that you have
mentioned okay make sense so yeah
so just to comment on um you you
mentioned the disguise part because it's
it's it's actually interesting you have
where Jesus um didn't want people to to
recognize him right uh he wanted to keep
a low problem
yet some people noticed him and
recognized him right then you have
examples after the resurrection where he
appears to some his disciples or the
followers and he does disguise himself
in a way that they can't um they're walk
he's walking right with them and they
don't know that they're talking to Jesus
and then he opens their minds and then
boom they see that they're talking to
Jesus so you we have these two instances
where okay why here doesn't Jesus just
disguise himself in a way that is
completely hidden from their minds or
whatever and then here we see that he
can
well I think it's we got to take into
account the stages of the mission and
his purpose so one you have before his
resurrection that he is um he has
completely you know humbled himself to
this servant especially in this human
life to where he's not transforming his
figure or doing all this kind of
magnificent Godly stuff you know um
every every second like he's actually
truly living a human life versus after
his resurrection those Li he not you
know uh and by the way this is all his
Free Will he's not um limited to the
human limitations anymore but has
glorified he's in his glorified State
and where he's not now he's act acting
in these ways now right um going to the
part about Jesus claiming to be the son
who has the authority to raise the dead
on Judgment Day um and that he's the one
who's giving them eternal life that so
when if you say um this could have been
just a maybe a a Corruption of the text
my my problem with that is
that you you you quoted like the the
patches right before it you know what
I'm saying like in in in its context
this the same conversation the same
thing so to say that when he says I came
to not to do my own will but the will of
the him who sent me but then to say that
the next verse might be corrupted that's
like well how do we know that the the
verse prior of that wasn't corrup this
is a good that that's actually that's
actually a good point and again the
answer to that from an Islamic ological
perspective is this is one of the
reasons the Quran comes now from an
academic perspective academic
perspective and as I started to share
with you John sh span and from an
academic perspective you know an
academic would argue exactly what you
just said what do what what do we what
can we trust you know regard regarding
information about Jesus so that's an
academic secular perspective and but
Islamic religious perspective is that
this is why the Quran comes so the Quran
isn't you know isn't coming and and
giving a commentary on each and every
single thing in the New Testament or the
Old Testament the Quran isn't doing that
but what it was doing is is focusing on
the major points so when you focus on
the major points again this is Islamic
theological perspective when you focus
on the major points then you start to
see what is
plausible and what is not
plausible can I comment on that yeah
yeah yeah so I I think that if so you're
basically you're you're doing it back
you're reading the the gospel right and
taking Jesus's words from through the
lens of of Islam through the lens of the
Quran which can possibly distort what he
really says because you're looking at it
you're saying okay if he says this he
can't really mean that he's actually
going to be the one raising the dead it
has to be something so I mean I hear
what you're saying I respect what you're
saying but the side could also be true
the flip side being that you know
perhaps you're looking at it from a
certain perspective and and not allowing
yourself to see it from other Angle now
again so you have two religions who are
looking at text and having
interpretation of text and then then
then the The Outsiders meaning uh
secular biblical studies secular
academic studies you who would look at
this and this is what this is partly why
I went to the issue of John Shelby span
is
is how they would look at it it's that
the the entirety of these of these
narratives you know you know has been
created for certain reasons to line up
with New Testament uh uh sorry Old
Testament text and that these have been
created you know for certain for certain
political or or ideological reasons yeah
so so that's my answer to to that but
from a again from a Muslim perspective
Muslim perspective is Jesus existed
Muslim perspective is that Jesus was
someone whom God sent Muslim perspective
is that Jesus was Messiah now we don't
agree about what Messiah means between
Muslims and Christians there's a
disagreement as to what the the term
Messiah means but nonetheless we we
believe him to have been Messiah for the
for the children of Israel we believe
that
so so the see so what I'm so yes we are
interpreting or I am I don't want to
speak for everybody I am
understanding the identity of Jesus
Through the lens of the Quran making
zero apology for that absolutely
absolutely zero apology for that and and
it gives me frankly it it it gives me an
appreciation for who Jesus was it gives
me an appreciation for what his mission
what his mission was now I know that the
we understand the mission very very very
very differently but I I I would not
believe in Jesus unless it was for the
Quran I believe in Jesus because of the
Quran not because of the Bible so would
you say then
um like
okay because how I like to do it I I I
try my best to just let the text speak
for us like even when we was just
talking about the Quran right yeah yeah
and how I wasn't coming at the Quran
from a Christian perspective I I was
literally seeing what the Quran says and
I saw and I let the Quran speak like on
what it says about the previous scri I
mean you can say that but that doesn't
mean it's true and that doesn't mean
you're lying but it means that as a
human being with with a certain premise
certain Foundation even if you claim to
not be looking at it from uh from just a
Christian lens I mean in fact you are I
mean so there's no need for us to
pretend I I'm not you're smiling of
course you are smiling you make me smile
man you make me smile but no seriously I
look I have
this I have this whole thing where like
I I say I have this saying we just read
right which which means that we we're
going to let whatever text we're looking
at speak for itself so so if if I may if
if I may um in the time after the time
of the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him there was among the things that
happened there happened to have been a
rebellion uh against the fourth khif
named Ali the prophet son-in-law and to
make a long story short he meets with a
group of rebels they called theage and
after the meeting these are people who
will quote the Quran and so on and so
forth and so he makes a statement their
words are true but their meaning their
their meaning is false okay so it so
what I'm trying to say in this sense is
you know and I'm I'm trying to be very
realistic here is that if if you're
you're you're you you've made a uh um a
life of of uh having these types of
discussions okay yeah and you have you
have you've read the text uh in
in with with the with having in mind you
know these types of discussions so you
you take your initial beliefs or
opinions with you unless God happens to
allow you to see it in a different way
then which is ultimately God's business
but but um I don't think it's really
accurate to say that you're just reading
text because you're reading you're read
because you're you're again you're
reading it from from uh from your
theological perspective that's what
you're doing I'm not let me tell you why
okay it's for example like this Imam
yeah like the Quran says that Muhammad's
the last prophet he's the Seal of the
prophets okay okay I don't believe that
okay now I'm not going to I can't come
to you and say the Quran doesn't say
that it doesn't say exactly what it says
that he's the Seal of the prophets or
try to you know interpret seal of the
prophets differently than what it
actually says like to try to people do
by the way people do and they're wrong
though right they're wrong cuz that it
plainly says what it says so that's
that's what I'm saying like I don't
believe this I don't you don't believe
Muhammad the prophets but but I which if
I understand what you're saying you're
saying is for using an example that you
don't believe Muhammad is the prophets
but you're acknowledging that the Quran
says Muhammad is the prophet is that
what you're saying yes that's exactly
what I'm saying so so with the Bible we
see that Jesus is he claims to be the
unique Son of God who's going to judge
un Judgment Day and rais the dead he
says it over and over again not just not
just in John 6 5 and all over the place
Matthew and stuff so we see these
passages and we like we we can't say
that okay well you know Jesus doesn't
really mean this he does he's saying
he's the son who has the authority to
raise the dead at his voice on Judgment
Day they're going to listen to him and
he's going to decide who goes to heaven
and who goes to hell so let me ask you a
question um so what about the people who
came before Jesus in what Regard in the
regards like let's say you have in the
time of Moses okay now you have people
people who followed Moses and people who
rejected Moses yeah and so these the
followers of Moses died they're dead
yeah okay they've been dead for however
many thousands of years yeah so my
question to you is on the basis of what
you just
said does Jesus have authority over them
100% and that and that he that and and
that he resurrects them yes and and and
that
if uh what about the fact that they live
before his time does this affect their
salvation according to you well no and
here's why because so um this goes into
the the deity of Christ cuz the
scripture talks about how he is there
even at that time matter of fact um it's
the book of Hebrews and Jude that
reference that Jesus was the one who was
there matter of fact if we go to you got
it open if you go to Jude uh and it's
only one it's in the New Testament um
Jude um one it's only one chapter it's
like it's going to be like kind of
towards the end yeah after after the
Epistles of
John so go ahead yeah what you want to
share so so
basically um Jesus is there you know
he's there with the people of Israel
he's there giving Revelation through
Moses and you know through the prophets
and stuff like that and so um and really
the message is is pointing to it's
foreshadowing the his coming it's
foreshadowing him the sac the animal
sacrifices the the feast days all this
kind of stuff it points these are
foreshadowings of the coming Messiah and
people who believe in what God is
revealing is looking to that not with
the full Revelation pieces of it but
they're looking towards it and so
because they believed and they followed
the laws of God they will be judged
accordingly when Christ raises them up
in that day to put it very simply okay
I'm not sure how simple that was I know
but um okay I I I hear I hear what
you're saying and I I have a couple of
uh a couple of thoughts but I'm I'm
actually going to kind of maybe Circle
back to that in a minute and and go to
this uh this other part so the other
part is is regarding the identity of
Jesus um because what you're saying here
what you basically have just expressed
is that Jesus emerges uh as the
sacrificer lamb and that the sacrifices
that were taking place in the Jud Jewish
practice that this foreshadows his
ultimate sacrifice did I understand you
correctly yes sir all right good
now now how does this go in long so the
Bible Old Testament it says more than
once it says the father shall not be
iniquities of the son neither shall the
son be the iniquities of the father
right and then the in the beginning of
the Gospel of Matthew it has John the
Baptist peace be upon him say produce
fruits and keeping with your repentance
the point I'm making
is in addressing your bigger issue your
bigger your bigger because you just
basically what you what you just
expressed is the idea that Jesus comes
to be the sacrifice for original sin
yeah so I'm gonna go back to the other
part in a minute don't let me forget
sure but I well well you know you got
you know I'll give you some paper you
can I'm I'm gonna give you some paper so
you can yeah I'm serious I'm gonna give
you some paper you got extra pen too I
have an extra pen to um well here
there's that pen I'll choose another one
so don't don't me forget to go back to
that okay all right
so one of the things that again one of
the things that the Quran comes to do is
comes to give clarification on these
important matters now the now the
matters you're referencing here is again
dying for mankind sins but you have ver
all you have examples throughout the
Bible of individual responsibility for
uh for one's actions the one the the
father shall not be punished for the
iniquities to the son neither the son
shall be punished for the iniquities to
of the father and so the Quran uses this
language it says that no no soul Bears
burdens of other soul of other of others
yeah and so there is a sense of
responsibility that each and every
single human being
has and from a from a logical
perspective does it make sense that the
Son of God or God himself however you
want to look at it that the Son of God
comes the first of all the idea that God
is going to kill his own son in order to
be a Redemption for mankind sins number
one or if you look at it as is Jesus
being God himself that he in in essence
commits suicide in order to atone for
Humanity sins in his own sight you know
so it it's it's a it's a it's it's you
know it's it's uh you know I'm sorry to
say it like this but it's not it's it's
uh it's it's kind of irrational it's
kind of an irrational premise fair
enough you know somewhat of irrational
premise so how the Quran addresses this
is that in many ways um I almost want to
go into the Adam and Eve discussion but
I don't know this they have time for
that but um how the Quran addresses this
is basically to make summarize the story
is that first of all every human being
is accountable before God yeah there
that that we don't inherit the sins of
Adam and Eve we don't we don't inherit
the sin so all the theological premises
of of um of of that you know Muslims
don't really uh accept you know in light
of the guidance from the from the Holy
Quran yeah so uh okay so the the premise
of you know Christian
salvation um any you're quoting Ezekiel
18 where I think there's other places
not just Ezekiel 18 okay but anyway go
ahead I'm sorry yes so yes Ezekiel 18
where you know um the son will not take
on the sins of the father father take on
the sins of the son but every the soul
that sins shall die yeah exactly that so
that's Ezekiel 18 um and then so if you
continue reading then this is the part
he talks about how the person if the
wicked person repents and turns from
their sins and he says and follows my
statutes and obeys my commands then I
will remember his sins no more right and
here's the important part of that phrase
is if they obey my statutes now God's
statute when it came to repentance was
substitutionary sacrifice right so yes
they are to um they are responsible for
their own sin however there is a mean by
how they are to repent that God has
established and that's substitutionary
sacrifice a lamb or a goat right um
instead of them God just destroying them
right on the spot so he allows a
substitute um in their place to carry
their sins at least for the meantime
which is why they had to keep doing it
over and over because it couldn't last
now with that being said also because
this is Ezekiel in Ezekiel 16 God says
that he's going to be the one who who
atones for the sins of man that they
can't do it themselves he's going to do
it right and so we're seeing this thread
God says he's going to be the one who
atones we see that he has set up you
know um substitutionary sacrifice
atonement um and he says that through
and you know repentance is through the
blood forgiveness is through the blood
right um that's Leviticus 17 so we see
that God has established this and he
says he's going to be the one to atone
for man's sins they can't do it there's
nothing that we can do are you saying
that God himself dies God himself dies
yes that God God himself listen to
yourself God himself put these three
words together uhhuh God himself dies
that's what you're saying let me let me
let me finish it let put the quotation
Mar I'm trying to wrap it I'm trying to
wrap it okay let let me all right okay
so when you're saying that God himself
dies that sounds me not me not me that's
your statement yes you're saying that
sounds outrageous that's crazy right you
I said that's your statement that's your
statement okay here's the here's the
thing though yeah God God obviously in
his divine nature cannot cease he cannot
die right death is not ceasing to exist
but it is the separation of the body and
the Soul so the only way for God to be
able to experience death because it's
impossible in his divine nature is to
take on flesh when he takes on flesh he
is able to then separate soul from body
and experience death that's why so God
can die according to the flesh not his
divine nature which is why Jesus and
understand the Incarnation is important
we're not saying that God in his divine
nature and omnipotence dies in his you
know divine nature no he took on flesh
and and by the way this is what Jesus
says he says no one takes my life from
me I lay it down of my own accord no one
can take it from me I lay it down myself
and I take it back up again right with
this being said this shows goes to you
know what you're saying about well if
you're saying that God then takes it
upon himself to do this then he just is
you know you have God committing suicide
to appease his own wrath this is
irrational and so it's not suicide it's
a sacrifice there's a
difference okay so regarding the last
part that you you
said the Bible itself is the crucifixion
has Jesus say my God my God why have you
forsaken me so if he saw himself as as
this as this uh someone who has come to
sacrifice himself for for original sin
for mankind sins if he saw himself like
that
why would he make that kind of a
statement that's number one okay and I
need to I'm saying I want to go in in
order so the next thing let me see my
the next thing is really you know that
first of all like why would God even
want to experience death so God now God
Is We believe that God is omnipotent
that God is omnipresent God is all
knowing god is all hearing God is all
seeing God is all wise so why would he
want to quote unquote experience death
This is really this this is one of the
reasons why monotheism is important or
as Muslims call it is important because
it it removes these kinds of uh uh um
weakened attributions to the
Divine okay okay um yeah one thing you
mentioned here I'm I try to keep
everything is God atones for the sins of
man and I'm going to talk about that in
this this one sense
um is that you know in the Quran
it has the same story of Adam and Eve
that they they disobey god theye of the
tree the difference between the quranic
narrative and the narratives given
within the judeo Christian tradition Nar
Jud Christian tradition is that
according to the
Quran not only did God um forgive Adam
and Eve it says it
says that not only did God forgive them
but God even taught them how to repent
and then in chapter 7 of the
Quran or maybe it's chapter 8 it it says
the words are as follows I just say them
in English it says our Lord we have
wronged
ourselves and if you do not forgive us
if you do not have mercy on us we shall
be among those who are in a state of
consistent Perpetual loss so the first
line of
that the the first line of that is is
really the secret to repentance the the
secret to repentance is acknowledgement
of your own mistakes that's that's the
first secret of of repentance okay and
so so because of that we are not
according to Islam at least I know your
perspective is very different but
according to Islam we are not held
responsible for the actions of our
grandparents of our ancestors we are not
we're not we're not held responsible for
that what Adam and Eve ate what fruit
they ate and we're not we're not held
responsible for that right right yeah
same with same with us as well um we're
not responsible for Adam eating the
fruit however we're responsible for our
own sins but we're you know born with
this inclination and this nature to sin
and rebel against God more so than to
obey him and do right that's that's
that's the well I mean I I hear what
you're saying I hear what you're saying
it's a philosophical discussion um don't
know if that's necessarily I don't not
not just from my own theology but from
my own experiences as a human being I
don't really see that as is that humans
are or so of just like born evil isn't
there a movie like that the born evil or
something but yeah yeah not born born
evil but born with the inclination to
you know rebel against God rather than
to completely submit to him so the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon Him is
reported to have said that every
child is born on the pattern of of he
uses the
term yeah so every child is born upon
the F yeah and yes the environment might
turn that child into this or that but
every child is born upon the fitra yeah
and in in the F it may not understand a
language a particular language or
particular rituals but you know in terms
of of of uh submitting to the role that
God has made for for him or her yeah so
go ahead okay yeah so um to to talk
about your questions because you asked
some really good ones about so you know
he's Jesus Is God but then why in the
world is he crying out you know on the
cross my God my God why have you
forsaken me if one this was his mission
in the first place does this doesn't
really sound like someone who uh planned
to do this if they're feeling forsaken
so there's two an two ways to tackle
this one um so the scripture the
previous scripture tells us about how
what Jesus ex would be
experiencing um in this moment and so if
we read like Isaiah 53 it talks about
how um The Suffering servant who's being
pierced for his trans for our
transgressions crushed for our
iniquities it says this it says that he
is a man of sorrow and acquainted with
grief and he carries our sorrows and our
weaknesses and our and our despair So In
This Moment In not just there but you
see see it in the Garden of Gethsemane
when he's praying intensely and you know
y y y right you see that he's acquainted
with this sorrow full of Despair and all
this all this kind of stuff um that's
what the scripture tells us he would be
feeling and going through and this is
real this and all of this is pertaining
to his Humanity he's taking this on and
is experiencing this pertaining to his
human nature the grief the despair the
sorrow the you know all that kind of
stuff so that's that's one okay we
expect him to this way and it's a real
feeling right um two when he says that
he's actually quoting Psalm 22 which
you're probably most already familiar
with this he quotes Psalm 22 which
literally almost in detail talks about
what is going on with him at the cross
that the one the feeling he's feeling
you know why are you so far from saving
me you know from my words of groaning
talks about how he's surrounded by his
enemies they're mocking him let the Lord
save he Delights in him which is what
they're saying to him at the cross um
he's he's thirsty and he's his tongue
sticks to his jaw his bones are out of
joint and he says you laid me in the
lust the dust of death um uh Bulls
surround me lions and you know they they
Encompass me they have pierced my hands
and my feet and then it talks about how
they he says they take my garments and
they divide my garments and cast lots
over them so in quoting the psalm the
ver very first like you know how you
guys would recite Quran and if a Muslim
recites the first verse of a Quran they
oh yeah they catch on they already know
right similar to that that's how it was
with the Jews you recite a Psalm they
got it's like reciting a Psalm um they
they would know what he's talking about
what he's quoting and it will still
point to him being the Messiah who is
the suffering servant of the Lord that
they're doing so that's so just a
summary um one the scripture tells us
he'll be feeling that acquainted with
our grief acquainted with our uh Despair
and that's what he's feeling in this
moment it's real feeling and then twoo
it's prophecy he's even quoting prophecy
that points back to his event so for the
letter part I'll get reference you than
John Shelby span okay uh I I didn't
think to bring the book with me but you
know he has a discussion on pretty much
all of these things uh his book is uh
reclaiming the bible let me make sure I
have that but I think it's reclaiming
the B Bible for a modern world okay so
he you know he all of these issues all
of these texts he he talks about in his
and his analysis is basically he he see
and again he wasn't a joke of a scholar
uh but he his analysis of this is
basically that this was this was a
literary Creations like so he doesn't
see it he doesn't see it as actually
happened and and they give you another
not that I cosign on to everything that
he has written but one of one of the
titles of his books is why Christianity
why Christianity must change or die
that's one that's the book he wrote I
think in the late '90s
the later book which I was more
referencing is reclaiming the Bible for
for modern world so you may have to
first of all might have to read that
that part um the the other part let me
see I understood you again so you said
that basically that Jesus as function as
Messiah I'm make sure I'm representing
you properly that you're saying that
Jesus had uh um come to basically you're
saying is that is that he not only does
he fulfill prophecy you're trying to
answer my question as to why he made
that prayer but is you're saying that
it's just it's just a function of him
being human is that basically what
you're saying that is he has
intentionally wanted to experience human
human suffering is that what you're
saying yeah so so yes it's both of that
so he's he's experiencing that human
suffering and that human despair but he
wants to experience human suffering
that's what you're saying yes that's
what he came to do so so so okay if he
comes to experience human suffering then
he shouldn't be crying to God my God my
God Li forsaken me because I mean that
term I mean however you Dice it however
you look at this story it it puts a dent
on God as being omnipotent it put it
it's really it has a number of
self-contradictions therein that that
okay he he said he comes to experience
human suffering so he wants to
experience it but then and then when he
experiences he says he tells God his
father let me clarify why why you
forsaken me let me clarify go ahead so
so it's not to experienc human suffering
but that he will because of the purpose
he came which is to save us so aren't
those synonymous terms not not really
like coming coming coming to like I came
here to experience human suffering
that's that's not the purpose the
purpose is to save Mankind and through
that he's going to experience human
suffering right so that's what he's
that's what's going to happen um and so
when we see him crying out my God my God
why have you forsaken me that's one he
is he really is experiencing that human
suffering and that despair but at the
same time too he's quoting a Psalm that
points to him in his event so I I yeah
and again I'm referencing John spons in
that but what I'm what I'm I'm the core
thing that I'm trying to uh to say is
that that even this this ignore for the
sake of conversation that okay that this
is a statement from Psalms for the we
can't no no no no for the sake of
conversation I mean we can come back to
it you just give me 5 Seconds okay
that's that's like the big you know the
crutch of it no what what I'm what I'm
saying here is that you know in you know
in all honesty it it to me it it's a bit
it's a bit of a self-contradiction it's
it's like someone who uh who wants to do
uh they want to harm themselves right
like someone who wants to harm
themselves and then they they then they
start to complain when they harm
themselves I mean it's to me it's it's
it feels like a self-contradiction would
would you okay so would would you have
that thought if the the statement is uh
is purposeful right like it's not just a
mere complaint of suffering but it's
it's it's this particular he could have
said anything with regards to his
suffering he
specifically quotes the words verbatim
of Psalm 22 that talks about his
crucifixion but you okay maybe I'm not
being being clear I mean I I you're
saying I he's
he's quoting Psalms I I hear what I hear
what you're saying okay but I'm I'm
trying to look at this from a from a
rational perspective from a from a
rational perspective again I already
quoted John Sly span and you can read
that for for yourself at your at your at
your leader what what does they what do
they say about his him referring to the
prophecy so in essence what what John in
his book and his book is is essentially
an analysis of the entirety of the Bible
and you know his books have the same
General themes but um in the book I'm
referencing reclaiming the Bible for a
modern world he you know these you know
all the stories you know that he argues
that these have been you know these are
Creations that these are these are so
these are Fabrications and they made it
fit or something they made yeah the
Fabrications and made it fit and so he
gives some examples like even the Lord's
prayer that Christians quote that that
that this is also a fabrication is he a
myth mythicist or something he was if I
remember correctly he was a he was the
Presbyterian Bishop of Newark and he's
passed away now um you know if I had
really thought about I would have
brought the book uh to to show you but
uh you know he he was he's a he was a an
a religious academic and uh you know you
can perhaps make your own if if he's if
he's saying that like because it kind of
sounds like he's taking like a a Mythic
approach to this that all this stuff is
is fabricated to fit one piece or to
convey a particular message on purpose
yeah but he he he would have to he would
have to um reconcile the the links where
you have Jesus crying on the cross you
have Psalm 22 before there's any anybody
to make up this story you have there
well yeah I mean okay he you have these
statements there and I'm I'm sure he has
his own views of Psalm 22 but I'm I'm
saying in this particular account cuz
I'm aware of the the idea that Jesus as
uh as substitutionary sacrifice you
according to Christianity that he's
fulfilling he a fulfillment of certain
texts in the Old Testament I'm aware
that that is what the Christian claim is
I'm aware of that what I'm saying in
connection to what John Shelby span just
said I hope I'm even saying his name
right might it might
be yourself it might be sponge might be
sponge SP o n g okay I I don't I don't
I've never some I've never been sure how
to pronounce that last name but anyway
he's made the argument on this issue and
on most of the most of the most of the
uh bi the famous actions of Jesus
according to the New Testament he's made
the argument that these were all
creations you know meant to align why
were they created they're they're
created to
align with with Old Testament texts so
if that's the case now your other
question was well okay okay fine it's
it's created but Psalms 22 is still
there that's what you said earlier right
it's still there regardless of if it's a
creation not a creation this got to be
fulfilled somewhere this is this is your
point I get your I I get your point and
and then for for a Muslim like I said as
a Muslim you're going back to the
Islamic theological premises the Islamic
theological premises is going back to
our previous discussion on the Bible our
the Islamic theological premises is that
you've had areas of interpolation
misunderstandings outright corruption
however you want to put it that have
occurred within the body of the of these
texts which is created certain ideas
religious ideas important religious
ideas that the Quran comes along to
address and how does how does it address
it IT addresses it by saying that
every that no soul Bears the burdens of
others so Jesus doesn't die for our sins
that that that that so that's that's
that's one of the premises that it says
but you want to say something yeah CU I
CU that that doesn't it doesn't fix the
issue for me you know you have you have
where Jesus conveniently cries out the
words of Psalm 22 that point to him
being having his hands and his feet
pierced and his clothes gambled over
which is what what the Roman soldiers do
to his garments right to say oh they
created this to for this to be there
well that doesn't solve the problem that
Psalms is there this is a thousand years
before the gospel is written yeah but I
mean you I mean you know how many people
were were crucified between the time the
Psalms was written into the lifetime of
Jesus they had the a lot of people a lot
of people crucifixion but no no what I'm
saying here what I'm saying here is that
the scenario at least the elements that
you shared you may Shar the scenario of
the of soldiers who are gambling over
his clothing right you shared the
scenario of his hands and feet being
pierced right I mean and they mocking
him for saying moing yeah yeah so and by
and by the way there were a number of
people who claimed to be Messiah but let
me let me stay
focused how many people were killed in
that way between the time that the
Psalms is written and the time of Jesus
that there had to have been I mean what
I'm saying here is that scenario is
applicable in thousands of other
scenarios it's not let me tell you let
me tell you why so so one crucifixion
didn't exist when the Psalms was written
that came a few hundred years later so
how is the Psalms describing um a a a
way of death that depicts a crucifixion
before it's invented this shows prophecy
it shows a revelation that he's talking
about so something specific two you have
this specific figure is in actual what's
what's the text you're talking about
Psalm 22 all right you remember the
verse uh verse 16 and 18 okay but it's
really the whole thing it's really one
it's you put one also verse one because
that's where he quotes it verse one and
then it's through the rest right okay
okay
so uh so it's depicting a death a death
by crucifixion before crucifixion is
invented a few hundred years before and
then the person it's talking about
specifically the servant of the Lord
clearly who um Delights in God who
trusts in God who God has sent and who
then um is surrounded by the people that
he came to they're mocking him saying
the Lord he trusts in the Lord let him
deliver him right the same stuff they
were saying to Jesus At The Cross he's
the son of God let him come down he
trust in God let him let him save
himself right and then and then having
his hands and feet pierced and having
his clothes divided and his garments
gambled over these are details okay okay
so what I'm saying here is let's look at
it let's look at the piece piece by
piece okay first first piece of well I'm
going out of order but first piece is is
the gambling away of of clothes I mean
that that that could that I mean I could
I don't I don't know how you can see but
I can see that that could happen in in
many scenario of anyone's being Mom I'm
serious come on man I'm
serious okay I'm serious I'm serious I I
mean in the real world in the real world
sense when they they executing somebody
whether it's deserved or not I mean that
that kind of scenario is is e it's easy
to be easy to to happen that's that's
number one what's the other scenario you
said the piercing the piercing of the of
the legs of the I'm sorry hands hands
and feet the person hands and feet mean
this is something that also that you
could you see in in in an execution
scenario and then the other one what was
the other one they uh one he cries out
my God my God why have you forsaken no
no no something else wasn't the the
mocking uh no the mocking the mocking
the mocking the mocking the specific
sayings let the he trusts in the Lord
let him save him he he he Delights in
the Lord let him deliver him but I'm
saying like like this I mean those
scenarios I mean I mean it's rationally
can be applied in any context no it can
yes it can all right who I mean anybody
who executed I mean look look look I'm G
give I'm gonna give you I'm gonna give
you a modern example okay when Saddam
Hussein was executed in I think 200000
probably 2005 2006 when when they
executed Saddam Hussein the is you can
see the footage on the internet his
executioners were making fun of him they
were saying they were say they they were
saying things to him right was they were
making insults to him and it's it's on
film was he crucified no he was H he was
hung he wasn't crucified but what I'm
saying here is that the scenario and and
by the way I meant to talk about
crucifixion yeah I meant to talk about
crucifixion now now
crucifixion um let me let's back up here
now you said that you said that yeah
yeah you said that crucifixion was
invented hundreds of years later after
Psalms that's what you said right okay
okay so how do you reconcile that with
what is said in the Old Testament the
Old Testament is the one who was hung on
a cross or on a tree is cursed how do
you how so so if
crucifixion because this is not an
argument I've heard before if
crucifixion was uh something that was
invented hundreds of years later how do
you reconcile that what the what the
Bible itself says what the Old Testament
itself says that the one who hung on the
cross or hung on the tree is cursed yes
how do you reconcile that it's because
so sin is the curse that we deal with in
mankind that's the part I'm talking
about the I'm trying I'm trying to help
you reconcile it's it's it's theological
it's completely theological right so the
Bible says that sin is our curse right
okay um and that um you know because he
takes on our sin he's taken on our curse
and so the Bible says that um he became
a curse for us by taking on sin he took
on sin and by being nailed to the cross
right being hung on a tree and there
therefore doing away with the curse
putting to death the curse then Rising
again in Authority putting it away all
together but that doesn't answer maybe I
wasn't clear with my question my
question was because you asserted that
the crucifixion I mean sorry the the the
the penalty of crucifixion was invented
hundreds hundreds of years later okay
all right that's what you said right
your point was so how could that it was
invented hundreds of years later so what
I'm saying here is if the Bible says in
the Old Testament if it says that the
one who's hung on a tree or on a cross
is cursed by God then that would show
that crucifixion existed as a punishment
in the first place yes yes yes so look
look let me let me let me let me comment
in a different angle okay so I know what
you're saying well let me come let me
come also let come also at a different
angle okay if if whether you use the
word
crucifiction or some other words you
know if you if you're talking about
somebody who was tied onto in this case
a tree or a or pieces of wood wood is
tree right it's it's a piece of tree so
you're still talking about the the same
thing now whether the term cross was
used in in in the Greek language or or
Aramaic or whatever language Hebrew
language whatever the term whatever the
term was you know is still the same uh
you still talking about the same thing
if I say this is a in Arabic this is
it's still talking about a pen so it's
another word but still talking about the
the same the same thing so what I'm
trying to what I'm what I'm trying to
make you I'm trying to to kind of prick
your mind here a little bit to to to
help you to see where I'm coming from is
that you know I I don't think that the
argument that you're sharing is really a
strong argument how I I explain how
because you're you're look you're saying
that the that the uh uh uh the
crucifixion was something like how could
how could um how could it be how did you
say how could it be that the the uh uh
so the psalmist is is describing a a
crucified death before crucifixion is
even that's that's what your argument
yeah that's that's that's what your
argument is and what I'm telling you
from the Bible itself now rather the
term cross was used it wasn't whether it
was or not is not the point you know
again whether you call this a pen or you
call this colum or whatever so if the
Bible is describing a pen or describing
a crucifixion yeah if it's I mean it's
still I mean what I'm what I'm trying to
say here is that you're because your
your evidence was that that crucifixion
was invented hundreds of years later and
this is a proof of of a prophetic role
okay that's your point right yeah yeah
and I'm and I'm saying that that doesn't
really make sense to me because of the
Bible itself the Bible itself again in
the Old Testament the text that we we
just talked about a few moments ago that
the one who's h h on the cross or or or
a tree that this is this is this is
someone who is cursed which is why
according to the Christian tradition
this is why they wanted to crucify Jesus
in that kill Jesus rather in that way
they wanted to show that he was cursed
so how does this how does this uh like I
guess show that my argument for Psalm 22
being prophetic how does that show that
it's not no what what I'm because of
what you said what you said was that it
was invented hundreds of years hundreds
of hundreds of years later and therefore
it's prophetic and I'm saying how could
it be evented hundreds of years later
when you have we have examples not just
in Psalms you have other examples where
it's very where that punishment was used
that's that was that was no no I I
didn't make up the quotation did I did I
make up the quotation that the one who's
Cur the one who's hung hung on a tree or
did I make up did I make that up let me
let me I did I make did I make that up
no you didn't all right all right don't
accuse me of a Shuffle Now of I won't I
won't I won't so so with with
Deuteronomy talking about you know
whoever is hung on a on a tree is cursed
um it it uses that particular L that's
that that's in general right so it could
be talking about anybody who's hung in a
tree at all all right or referring to
anyway right crucifixion would would
line up with that that would still be
prophetic but that's but my what my
point my point here is that as a my my
point is twofold in this example okay is
that number one that as a as a
punishment because you said it is it was
made hundreds of years later as a
punishment this type of punishment even
if they didn't use the word cross it
already is already existed that's my
that's my point okay but crucifixion
wasn't being a tree sure but crci I mean
I mean again what that comes to the
point too is that being hung on the
cross or hung on the tree or tied to a
tree this is this this is this is really
the same thing now if you want to use I
mean you want to have a choice of which
word to use being crucified is is a
specific way of being hung on a tree can
we say that that it's it like so if if
someone if someone look go ahead go
ahead yeah so we we can we can
understand that being hung on any Cross
Beam or whatever that's being hung on a
tree technically sure right but thank
you right so I agree with you but but
specifically the crucifixion style of
being hung on a tree that was not an
that was not an existence in Deuteronomy
or before PSAL so I mean if you you know
this is not something this not an
argument I've ever encountered but if if
I mean the argument I mean the um the
practice of the Romans were the
crucified political enemies yeah that
was that was their that was their
practice and perhaps to not just
political enemies but to but for uh uh
um for average criminals yeah right that
was that was one of the that was one of
the things they did they did and if I
not mistaken this this kind of
punishment does exist in other societies
you know the idea of of uh of
crucifixion what what so what I'm saying
is I don't get the aru what I'm trying
to tell you is I don't get that argument
as as evidence number one but number two
Let me let me you know I think we're
kind of like beating on the same point
um so maybe we should move on forward
move on to uh do do you have um cuz it's
6 o' now um I know we lost track of time
it's but is there is there something you
want to like hit on especially I want to
make sure we get to stuff that you
really want to get to we kind of H so we
yeah you know we've gone we've kind of
gone all all over the place but um there
the main things that I want to share is
is uh I'm G skip some of this so the
main thing I want to share is that you
know people think of Islam as a foreign
religion that it's worshiping a
different God that it has uh different
sets of values and and all of that but
what Islam actually is it is a it is a
continuation and a completion of the of
the teachings of The Messengers and
Prophets of God including Jesus it is
not an antichrist it is not out to
destroy people uh it is not out to
encourage immorality none of those
things at all that that when you look at
what Islam has done Islam has really is
revived you look at the time of Muhammad
the prophet or after the time of
Muhammad the prophet peace be upon him
you see the emergence of new
civilizations and the Revival of
previous civilizations and so what I'm
trying to say here is that this is this
was the this was part of the role all
along not just to pray in a certain
fashion but to bring forth morality to
bring forth order to bring forth peace
to bring forth love all of those things
that this that that so in a so in a
sense that the mission of Jesus frankly
and I know that Christians will not
necessarily agree or maybe you not
necessarily agree but the mission of
Jesus is completed with the coming of
Muhammad peace be upon them both and and
that even for those who disagree because
this is another another point that
people talk about you know for people
may disagree with with these religious
assertions fine let them disagree yeah I
was Interview years ago I used to be
able to find this on the
internet and basically there was there
was a there was a particular church that
did a program an anti-islamic program in
the media asked me for a interview and
because they arranged a
speaker you know talk about how Muslims
are going to hell and things like that
and they wanted my opinion and I said
look I don't care if they think I'm
going to hell as long as they don't try
to send me there that's what I said I
don't care if they think I'm going to
hell as long as they don't try to send
me there okay so so Muslims we have we
have our theology yes very strong and
and it's very deep you have to you may
not agree with anything I said but but I
think that you're going to start
thinking about this conversation it's it
is a very Nuance it's a very deep
religion and it has a positive impact on
the world but if people don't want to
accept it that's fine the Quran says say
truth is from your lord so him who will
accept it let him accept it and him who
will rejected let him reject it so so um
you know we're here to to share some
perspectives and you know frankly we
don't lose sleep right if someone says
what you what what what we're saying is
wrong we don't we don't lose we don't
sleep over that so that's where I'm
going to stop okay well I appreciate
that um you just in light of uh the
mission of Jesus and you're you're right
obviously we we disagree with the
Christian Perspective Jesus said on the
cross when he was being crucified he was
on there for hours bearing the sins of a
of a sa he said he looked up he said it
is finished and then he gave up his
spirit and and died and then rose again
3 days later but the important part
there is that it is finished and even
Jesus says he says says that he's the
son of God in John chapter 6 whom the
father has set his seal so you know for
us from the biblical perspective it it
starts and ends with Jesus not anybody
else not Muhammad to come later to
finish what Jesus started or could
complete his mission Jesus said that he
finished it that he fulfilled it and so
the the mission that Jesus came to when
he says that he came to uh fulfill what
Moses said about him what David and the
Psalms and the prophets spoke about him
and he says this in Luke 24 he says that
the Christ should suffer and on the
third day rise on the dead and that
forgiveness of sins should be preached
in his name starting from Jerusalem and
then to the rest of the Nations so he
says this is what this is about it's
about the gospel being spread and
whoever doesn't come because there a lot
of people going to come in his name
saying that they're in line with him
comeing preaching in his name saying
they glorify him saying they're on his
side right and there he says don't
believe them if they do not affirm the
gospel that you have heard the gospel
that I have preached do not follow these
people don't believe him so from the
Christian Perspective it's tough for us
to accept one somebody coming with
another revelation after Jesus because
that obviously implies that Jesus wasn't
enough it it wasn't finished um so
that's that's where that's where we
stand I mean you know that's that's fine
I mean you know I could
yeah we're we're we're done anywhere
we're done okay so I mean I I hear I I
hear what you're saying I do and it's
very easy for me to share a reply to
that but you know I don't think it's
really necessary I think you get the
general sense of of what um you know of
what we shared and you know again from
from my perspective and I think the
perspective of of Muslims generally you
know we're not losing sleep we're not if
a person doesn't want to accept the ISL
theological claims that's that's their
soul and that's their conscious and
that's their business you know is we're
not losing any we're not losing any
sleep we're not losing any money or
losing anything right um you know so
that's that's you know that's what said
it is it is what it is as as as as they
say so um um you know again from from
Islamic perspective we follow Jesus in
his authenticity we follow Moses his
authenticity and from Islamic
perspective we are
um um we are rejecting the excesses and
the exaggerations so the Quran
says this says do not do not exaggerate
in your religion you know so it says the
Christians don't exaggerate in your
religion 471 yeah
um that God is only the you know only
one God so um so yeah that's that's you
know that's I mean like I said it's it's
fine it's fine we're not
enjoyed this it was it was a pleasure
and an honor for you to sit down with me
and have this discussion I pray that it
blesses um both Christians and Muslims
alike and non-religious people who tune
in that they heard both perspectives and
uh was able to get clarity out of this I
hope that you guys um had a good time
listening to this so make sure you guys
hit the like button um and uh I hope
that you guys all enjoyed it um my name
is Avery this is Imam wahed and we guys
we'll see you on the next time all right
make sure you check out the previous
video on the authority of the scriptures
take care